what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey's here with the joint it's
monday the 13th and it's brought to you
by
on it listen they just had that black
monday friday cyber sale don't worry
about nothing i got you covered they
still got tons of alpha brain tons of
shroom tech tons of new mood tons of all
different alpha brain drinks and whatnot
they got plenty of kettlebells so do me
a favor you want to start the year off
on the right foot like i'm gonna say in
the podcast today listen i just started
another cycle alpha brain because you
want to be ready
by january 2022 so why [__] around go to
haunted.com right now take a look at
their supplements if i was you start
with the starter kit alpha brain a
little shroom tech immune get the it's
the winter you want to be tip top magoo
on your [__] brain and with your
[__] immune system no [__] around
so get on it.com right now take a look
at the kettlebells and the club bats and
stuff i can't get you a discount on that
but as far as the supplements i got your
back use code joey
church or joint and i'm giving you 10
off delivered right the house real quick
you'll get it all by the first so you
could be [__] have a great
2022. so go to honor.com
read see if you like it you're gonna
love alpha brain 100 money back
guarantee even if you don't use it
that's pure [__] belief
out for brain honor.com
code joey knock yourself the [__] out
we're going deep in 2020 2022 and i want
you to have all the [__] supplies on
it.com
use code joey the best the joint is also
brought to you by
me undies oh [__]
it's the most comfortable bear underwear
here to spread some holiday cheer i've
been working with me on these for seven
[__] years and they never seem
they never disappoint their underwear
are tremendous they're made mo doll
they're soft they cup your nut sack and
they keep your muffler and your balls
dry tremendous right there it's the
holidays and now they got holidays
sweater prints me undies is turning up
to comfort this season all meundie
products are made with soft breathable
stretchy fabrics i [__] love them
hand me undies just as an underwear
anymore they got loungewear
matching pajama sets plush robes
slippers and more i got some nice little
sleepwear i put it on this week oh my
god nice
the legs are warm the nut sack is kept
in place
they got something for grandma grandpa
aunts uncles
even your weirdo cousin if you want in
fact this is good i hate christmas
shopping i'm gonna get some of my undies
for a couple people so do yourself a
favor
go to me undies right right now they
have an offer for listeners of the joint
home
any first-time buyers get 15 off and
free shipping right to your door period
we got sizes from extra small to 4x me
undies has a little something for
everybody they got tremendous little
matching undies for mama this is it this
is your christmas present cut this [__]
right now go to meundies.com right now
slash joey i'm gonna get you 15 off your
first order free shipping and 100 money
back guarantee but it starts with you
this is the way to go you don't have to
go to stores and go shopping they got
christmas prints they got reefer prince
they got tremendous print i i had the
reefer ones on the other day i shot some
people at the gym i love all that stuff
i'm going to get you 15 off your first
order and free shipping with the
meundies.com
joey that's me undies dot com
slash joey the joint is also brought to
you by betterhelp.com
joey that better help is online therapy
better help is customized online therapy
they offer video phone even chat live
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to and it's affordable than
in person therapy but it starts with you
go to betterhelp.com
diaz that's better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot-com
slash diaz take control of your life the
way i'm going to take control this
candle
and get this party started jack it's
monday morning we got no time to [__]
around let's do this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 13th of december a
tremendous [__] day we did it another
week as here that's it the [__]
[__] is over with i'm feeling good
i'm looking good my balls are fresh what
do you want it's [__] monday you know
what i'm saying you gotta bathe you
gotta cut your toenails you got to be
ready for the next [__] week we got
two weeks that's i couldn't [__]
believe saturday night i was watching i
was at a christmas party
and we were just talking [__] you know
you don't really think about what's
going i know i don't
i'm just worried about today and [__]
making it on today
and somebody said it's two weeks away
from christmas i was like what the [__]
i was trying to listen guys i i know
that there's some things i [__]
attack
but there's some things i [__] uh
stray from
and it's like christmas because i know i
gotta go christmas i still have not
gotten
a [__] seed
nothing i haven't gotten my wife a
[__] thing i got a christmas present
that's it because i get double whammy
her chris my wife's christmas uh my
wife's birthday present is the 28th
so i got to come up with christmas
presents and then two days later turn
around like a [__] uh you know and
get another [__] present i don't know
if you guys know this i'm not [__] uh
captain tick tock magoo or going into
store i [__] hate
going into stores and this is for all my
life like going christmas shopping like
with a list
i go into a store or two i buy i already
know listen there's a mall close to my
house i already know everything's gonna
get done in that mall the christmas card
the little [__] designer jewelry i
usually get like this [__] jewelry
she likes it's like 10 bucks 20 bucks
i'm gonna have to go to like kohl's or
something and get her a blouse or some
[__]
and uh i wish i was gonna get her a
purse me and my daughter were gonna get
her a nice purse like we did a couple
years ago what happens she goes to bingo
and wins a [__] purse so i'm done
there so now i can't that's one gift i
can't you know because i don't know what
the [__] is going on with people you
know you give some cash you give some
gift cards then they tell you you can't
get [__] gift cards you know you go
to buy something for somebody thank god
i put my wife my wife does all that [__]
thank god she loves doing it so i pass
it on to her there's a couple people i
look at i don't even send the [__]
christmas card i'm so bad i wouldn't
even know where the [__] to start i
never sent christmas cards when people
send me christmas cards i feel like a
[__] [__] like look at this
this is [__] terrible you know and
you hang their cards up to celebrate
them and [__] but it's not enough unless
you send the card but for me to sit
there one night
and just write christmas cards i don't
see myself [__] doing it i'm sorry
some people are good at that [__] some
people are not
you know and don't feel bad because for
years i've been beating myself up over
this [__] i like christmas let me tell
you something i'm gonna tell you the two
reasons why i left l.a today because
i've been really thinking about it
one of the reasons and i'm gonna tell
you how it went down just so you know
i'm not a [__]
sack of [__] here
i went to a christmas party all night
when i left i'm gonna drive home i go
terry how many of those do we do in l.a
and that's the first one out of the
[__] 20 that we're going to
you know like all the kids we hang out
with their family all has a
uh a different way to celebrate
christmas like one's doing did one
saturday night and it was uh what's that
[__] when you just give one person a
gift silent secret santa for the kids
you know that was great yeah no no that
was great there was 20 people there
there was more [__] dessert than
there was food and there was a ton of
[__] food like i know i'm in jersey
from pizza to sandwiches to lasagna to
meatballs i mean these [__] people
did it right you know
and here's the funny thing on the way
home
we were dr we were driving on the way
home and i said to my wife you know
how many of those did we do in l.a
you know that's all i wanted
that's all i wanted for it to feel like
christmas one [__] year
one [__] year for it to be okay it's
bad enough there's no snow
there's no cold weather everybody
[__] leaves like
already
uh la
well
it's been empty since [__] last july
and last august
but you could see if you live in l.a
right now people start leaving
which really sucks because
these are the people usually invite over
you know how many [__] years
i had like orphans over you know and i
didn't mind i love that [__] having
orphans over
people coming over eating some [__]
carvel cake talking some [__] it makes
you feel warm like it makes you feel
great when you can have people over and
open up your family other people let me
tell you something for years
people opened up their homes to me on
christmas eve so i know exactly how it
feels when you don't have any [__]
dough
and you gotta like scrape around your
house just to bring like the lady who's
inviting you over like an apple pie
like you have to go to [__] shop
right and get yourself an apple pie
that's on sale you can't even get like a
quality apple pie trust me yeah i've
been there guys i've been there so i
know what it is to feel shitty on
christmas so now
i can feel a little [__] better i
mean i'm not you know running through
the [__] streets jumping up and down
which we'll get to in a second and uh
you know i'm not [__] running up the
street but i enjoy christmas
and if i have a little something i like
to have some people over i always ask
hey you want to come over you know
whatever you want to stop by if you're
single especially if you're [__]
single i always tried to have [__]
people over in fact what killed me two
christmases ago what let me know i had
to leave l.a was i had a couple orphans
over no names and i had an orphan
brought a friend of theirs right
and i don't i don't give a [__] it's
christmas you open your door to
everybody and we're sitting there
yacking up and [__] down and the next
thing you know
this chick is telling me about
instagram friends
she gave me a 22 minute ear beating
on instagram friends her whole life
was revolved around [__] instagram
friends
and it was so sad like she she brought
me so down and cried and been that down
since they canceled the green horn in 68
i hadn't been that [__] down i swear
to god she brought me so down on the
holiday i'm like this [__] don't care
about christmas this [__] don't care
about her family she don't give a [__]
about
nothing all she cares about is her
instagram friends it was the [__]
loneliest thing i was like
i gotta get the [__] out of here and i
still remember rogan calling me and
going hey man
i'm thinking of moving to texas i like
to know if you want to come down blah
blah blah
and the first thing i said is what are
we going to do on christmas
you know like what i'm
i'm sick and tired of [__] just
sitting here on christmas eve
and i was like a die hard like i would
never leave
i left one year and i was back by the
20th and it was food it was money out of
my pocket because i usually book a lot
of
television from
thanksgiving to christmas eve
to the 19th 18th that's when the year
goes after that you're in no [__]
danger one year i booked a
[__] one year i booked an nfl
commercial on christmas eve i booked on
the 22nd
and we shot on christmas eve and the
[__] morning yes we did they paid us
double
i loved all that [__] [__] but the
dad was
the other night
mercy came downstairs and was watching
tv
i came from somewhere
and i was walking past and she was
scrolling
like she was hitting the numbers instead
of going on the [__] page and picking
whatever the [__] you want to watch
and she had something on and i
recognized the music right i'm like
i know this [__] music and i turned
around and it was
two and a half men after charlie sheen
left with the [__] ashton kutcher and
i look up and who do i see uncle joey
right i'm like
holy [__]
that's right i did the christmas one for
[__] uh
two and a half men like the last two
years they had it
dog they [__] called me one year
they're like hey
we want you to audition for two and a
half men i'm like what and i knew the
lady the casting lady for years she
never [__]
called me for anything she had booked me
and other things but i knew that she
cast the show
and she goes uh yeah i want you to come
in to read for this [__] role when
she sent me the sides for the audition
it was like
i don't even know what the [__] they
were i couldn't even i was like what the
[__] is this
it was everybody else was jumping up and
down and singing and i'm on the corner
with some guys that's what i broke it
down to
so when i went into the audition i go
what do i do she goes just stand there
and do whatever you want what would you
do if you were standing on the corner i
go that's a [__] great audition
picking my nose looking around i don't
[__] know scratching my balls she
started laughing she goes i don't know
do that so i was just doing that you
know like just [__] hanging out
whatever she goes thank you for coming
in i'm like that was a waste of my
[__] time thank god it was burbank it
was really [__] close to the house i
wasn't that angry well she called me two
days later she's like hey man
you got the part if you want to do it
i'm like
what
are you [__] serious she's like yeah
it shoots four days we're gonna give you
a flat feet no residuals
the flat fee wasn't bad i'm like [__] it
i'll take it but i was pissed because
it was a scene on the street
and all these dancers are singing down
the street and we're the last guys on
the corner
so when they were rehearsing all [__]
week
they were rehearsing other scenes they
weren't even looking at us
they were just going to walk past me
like as usual people just walked past me
they weren't going to stop and talk to
me nothing so i'm sitting there in the
corner and i'm like i finally me and the
other two [__] dudes the other dude
was my friend's cousin the most annoying
man in north america i had to wear
[__] you think i'm kidding you had to
wear those [__] things you put in
your ears he wouldn't shut the [__] up i
must have walked 20 000 steps those four
days just getting away from him the guy
would drive me crazy from the [__]
time i walked on the set
to the time i left it was a thousand
question charlie so i i was like this is
too much so i was dying to get the [__]
out of there so i went to the producers
i went to everybody i'm like listen
that camera don't get to us to the
[__] end and you guys are jumping up
and down the middle of the street can we
get the [__] out of here
you know what i'm saying like what are
we doing here we're just standing here
he's like nah because we might need you
later listen in the end
it worked out they [__] paid me i had
a great [__] time
would i do it again i don't know it was
the four longest days of my [__] life
the highlight was one night they had
like a little fake christmas party and
his girlfriend came everybody was
drooling all over what's her name
the little chick the i don't know what
[__] i
have to eat dumb [__] bruce willis
wife
that's when i did it right around that
malia kunis whatever [__] name is
she was on the set one night with some
of her [__] girlfriends and all the
other actors like oh my god malia
coolness let me see if i can get on the
[__] show
i went home i got my food and went them
they had a good [__] food though but
it's funny the other night did something
for myself not to get off the subject
but it's really weird how i get
not anymore i think that i talked about
it so much on all the general podcasts
that people got the hint about the
[__] woe is me routine
listen i get the wall with me routine i
love to use it from time to time myself
until i catch myself doing it like the
war was me routine and you're like what
the [__] am i doing you know i've had
other opportunities what am i crying
about this for so
i hate the woe was [__] me routine
and it's been
you know
i just was [__] up to last year so i
didn't know i it wasn't really a war
with me routine it was like i got to get
my [__] together so thursday night last
week
the gracie the jiu jitsu family was
having a a seminar
in [__] jersey here
a buddy of mine coach sean let me know
he goes you're you're more than welcome
you're invited you know they're gonna
have some food afterward and [__] let me
tell you something
you don't know what the word anxiety was
until [__] thursday
i woke up thursday had a great morning
did my patreon work
did some stuff with my wife i went to
the gym i worked out
and i had a [__] that night i had to
go it was just 6 30 we had to be there
you know
now i hate doing [__] at night the
reason why i do jiu jitsu and the gym
and everything in the morning
is because i gotta get it over with and
i hate sitting there all day with that
in my mind like if you have to go to
acupuncture at five you can't get high
all day you know what i'm saying like
it's just brutal
and i used to go to acupuncture at 12 30
and it was still brutal for me i would
get [__] high i mean i don't get high
in the daytime anymore
but when you're doing jiu jitsu at night
and all those you know late things you
got to watch what you put in your
[__] body like if you meet somebody
at five
and you go eat pizza and the pizza is
good and you get an extra slice you're
gonna go you gotta go to jiu jitsu with
those three or four [__] slices in
your stomach and let me tell you
something that shit's a [__]
nightmare to work out like i could lift
weights with breakfast in my stomach but
the [__] uh
you know do hip escapes and [__]
arm bars and [__] with nothing in your
[__] stomach it's goddamn brutal with
your stomach full is brutal especially
at night you've smoked already
you [__] breathe this terrible
[__] air all day
you have [__] with your mind your kid's
sick you need a babysitter so when you
go to train at night all that shit's on
your mind at least it is for me so i
just don't do well at night
so i'd rather i don't know if it was
because i was older i don't know what
the [__] it is i'd rather
get it over within the daytime this
seminar they don't do seminars in the
daytime unless it's saturday
this seminar was at night and it was
part of a christmas party let me tell
you something i was making excuses all
[__] day i haven't made these many
excuses
since i had to get up on stage and do
comedy the first time you should have
heard the excuse machine then
but and i don't say it because nobody
really knew my wife knew i was going to
the seminar nobody else really it's not
like i call my friends and go guess what
i'm going to a gracie seminar it's not
that at all they're like that's great
whatever no so i didn't say nothing i
just told my wife i go
i got to go to this thing thursday i
think it'd be really good for me you
know
and she's like in which way i mean i'm
like i just
a i get the [__] out of here at night
which i never [__] do b
i work out at night which i never do and
i'm my mind is uh
shifted and see
you know i go to jiu jitsu at night all
these street things are good i get to
talk to people they're going to have a
[__] they had a catered some barbecue
and [__] like that it's a party joey go
you're you're a [__] man go you you
know you could drink do whatever the
[__] you want i brought a little [__]
vaper pen with me those [__] abx pens
holy [__] where is my little abx man i
hit it before i was coughing my wife
thought i had covert and [__] it's
tremendous
this call this abx [__] is clean whether
it's the [__] edibles that 100
milligram 200 milligram
[Music]
i don't even know what flavor this is i
don't know what it is i just like it i'm
like [__] what
i don't know what it is i just like it
you know what i'm saying
but
what are we talking about all the
[__]
the who
the gracie
i was just giving myself excuses
i'm like i'm gonna eat at 5 30 so i
don't have to go but then something
happened i ate at four i'm like oh [__]
everything worked out
i set it up that way i had a late lunch
i had a late breakfast i had a late
lunch because my daughter had a [__]
half day and i said let me go down there
and i'll tell you guys i was doing like
15 miles an hour there i'm not gonna lie
to you it takes like 10 minutes it took
me like an hour that night
when i got there at 6 25 when i walked
in
there was 50 [__] people guys and
geez
guys in shape
guys that look like they [__] eat
right every day
you know and i walk in with my fat
little stumpy
white hair and i felt so [__]
insecure
but you know what people started shaking
my hand how you doing thank you for
coming bro i can't believe you came you
know [__] like that
and you feel good it felt great about it
it wasn't even the workout i was
dreading it wasn't getting beat up i was
dreading none of that [__] it was just
my own dread you put these own things
into your [__] head that's what the
art of war is about that book that we
that i go over once a year i'll go over
it now in january you know i found it
like three months ago and i started
reading a little excerpt from it i can't
read the whole book again i've read the
whole book like 20 times but i have
excerpts that are like uh outlined out
like little yellow i put like the
[__]
highlighter and i just highlight them
out and i'll read two or three chapters
and it gets you back on the [__] ball
because it's basically doing what you
don't want to do for yourself
i don't know what you know i can see you
don't want to jump off a building i
could see that you don't want to [__]
you know
go to i could see i could see all these
things but there comes something when
you're doing something for yourself
for years i wouldn't and then i started
thinking about when i go to the doctor i
don't go to the doctor for you i go to
doctor for me i go to the doctor because
it's one of my pet peeves so i make sure
i get there you have no idea when i
lived in [__] hollywood and i had to
go to the doctor
it was horrible
i would have my wife drive me
and then one day i go why is she driving
an adult male
to the [__] doctor
what what what the [__] is my problem
what do i need help so i just drive
myself i don't think about it i go in
there i take my medicine whatever the
[__] they're gonna give me they gotta
draw blood they gotta get you how many
[__] vaccines i gotta take in the
next couple weeks shingles
[__] there's another one i gotta take
marco conan pneumonia marco come on some
[__] [__] and all these vaccines hurt
like [__] crystalia got the the [__]
whatever one the one for chickenpox and
he's like my arm hurt for like a [__]
month i was dizzy
i don't want to take it but cvs has all
that [__] right there they have it all
in the [__] record there but if you
get your shot boom these are the things
you gotta look at when you're an old man
remember when remember paulie and the
sopranos when they show them cutting
coupons i'm almost there i'm not there
but i'm almost there i'm like dude i'm
like two or three [__] weeks away
from cutting coupons that's just that's
just what happens guys it's not that i
want to cut [__] coupons it's just
the [__] situation i got in front of
me
but it's just so weird i walked in there
guys
you know i had so much anxiety at one
point i thought i was gonna [__] pass
out i don't know if you guys ever get
that anxious when you go someplace and
you feel insecure
i just felt like i did not need to
[__] be there but guess what i needed
to be there
i talked to a few guys you know i knew a
few guys from going to classes there
you know not a lot of guys i know like
maybe five or six guys there was like 40
guys there for like a [__] even the
girls
looked [__] like they could beat me
up
so i just said [__] i went i went on
the [__] mat
i listened to what they had to say
there's a guy there that is uh about 10
years younger than me sweetheart of a
guy big [__]
he always works with me on the court
classes i we looked at each other we're
like let's go
so it was kind of easy i worked with him
and i swear to god that thing started at
6 30 i'm like
i'm out of here at eight
like joey dear [__] like i'm out of here
at eight you know what at eight o'clock
i was sweating like a [__] pig with
that muscle-bound guy on top of me i'll
never forget i made a mental note i'm
like what am i doing at 8 o'clock i
remember looking at the clock
and going it's eight o'clock you know
what i'm usually doing at eight o'clock
sitting here contemplating jumping out
of [__] window i'm gonna watch some
shitty tv shows something like that
i did that i was like all right i gotta
make up an excuse i gotta leave at 8 30.
at 8 30 i was still on my [__] back
sweating up the storm i said [__] it
i'll get out of here at nine at nine
they were doing the promotions for the
class because
and i said [__] it i'm just gonna stay
and i stayed i had barbecue with the
guys i talked with them
i walked in my house about [__] 10
30.
i'd never forget i didn't check my phone
for like three hours
when i went in my wife had texted me
like 18 times are you okay where are you
what's going on me and mercy are worried
about you i'm like what the [__] i go
out for three hours
and all of a sudden you're calling a 911
report what the [__] i'm going out you
know i mean they weren't mad or anything
they just know that i'm usually back
here pretty you know and i haven't been
driving distances lately
because i'm getting [__] carsick
again this is three car six now in two
[__] weeks
yesterday i went to get something and i
went on the way back i [__] had to
lay down took a nap for an hour and a
half in the afternoon you know when the
last time i took a nap in the afternoon
was not never i had no [__] idea when
was the last time i napped in the
afternoon because i'd have to drink
coffee i'm not getting high in the
morning but i had a [__] nap that's
how sick i was i think i got sick
monday night when i went to jimmy
florentine sons game on vandenberg and i
got sick two weeks ago when i was trying
to go down to frankie edgar's in the
seaside and i [__] puked so that
means for the next couple weeks till i
find out what's going on i don't know if
i'm trying to sit here going what did i
do the last two weeks that i've been
doing differently have i taken a vitamin
you know i'm i'm almost finished with my
[__] alpha brain
cycle i started in december because i
want to be tip
top mugu
january [__] first you know what i'm
saying because 2021 is not gonna be a
joke
i hope all you [__] are getting
ready for 2021 because it's gonna be a
[__] great year
2022 i'm sorry that's the reefer you
know what i'm saying that's 20 years of
smoking reefing guys and i just want you
to be [__] prepared it's going to be
a great year they're going to throw some
curve balls at you
don't think it's going to be ah [__] it
the omnichrome virus is gone
we're jumping up and down you're gonna
get some [__] curve balls at you
trust me what i'm telling you
be prepared but who gives a [__] the
most important thing is
that we keep [__] pushing and let me
tell you something else about 2022 i
want you to be prepared on we're
sponsored by better help online therapy
i
was the last person in the world
you could talk to about therapy every
sad move with the thief
with james come he tells you i'm the
last guy in the world you want to [__]
with
listen i'm the last guy in the world
that ever thought about therapy or
talking to somebody that's not my
[__] speed i don't know why i don't
know if it's because the cuban in me
the [__] criminal of me i don't know
what it was
when i was in the system and i was
forced
to talk to people it wasn't enjoyable
and when i was uh
after i got out of the system you know
they threw me through that [__]
serenity rehab
and uh i thought she was a nightmare
that woman but
when i ran into the snag i had after i
moved here you know i just had a lot of
issues i had been thrown with a lot of
stuff
i didn't know what to do i spoke to a
couple friends of mine and they were
like they're a lot smarter than i am
and they're like maybe you should you
know try some therapy i looked around i
called her back i said i can't find
anybody
i called the psychiatrist he was like
we're not taking any pay i must have
called 30 people
and finally one of my girls i grew up
with said listen i've been struggling
too the reason why you can't find
somebody is because everybody's
struggling
it's not just you
get therapy online and she referred
better help and let me tell you
something you guys have seen the
difference i've been with better help
uh
i've been with betterhelp.com since
about march and i feel great i took to a
lady there named dana once a week uh we
used to do morning but now we do night
times you know like six seven o'clock
listen it's great better help many think
people uh a lot of people think therapy
is for crazy people and that's not right
i mean listen i'm not saying i'm not
crazy but it means that you recognize
that we're all humans that we got
something going on and that we all have
emotions and need to learn to control
them sometimes they get out of hand
sometimes things come into my head that
are just too fast therapy is a tool to
utilize before things get worse
don't wait till things get unbearable
like i did i should have taken the hint
last march of 19
uh march 2nd but i didn't better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video phone and chat sessions with your
therapist you don't have to see anybody
on camera if you don't want to maybe
you're shy maybe you have a hard time
making eye contact it was the same thing
for me the other thing about better
health it's much more affordable than in
person therapy and you could start
communicating with your therapist in
less than 48 hours i think that's
tremendous also i talked to my therapist
this morning every monday 8 45
tip top magoo what i'm trying to suggest
to you is to give it a try and see why
over two million people have used better
help
online therapy listen just for the joint
listeners what i'm gonna do this month
i'm gonna give you 10 off your first
month
why is this crucial because it's
december you don't want to go into 2022
with you know thinking weird stuff you
don't know you're confused this is the
time to attack like i did don't wait for
life life ain't gonna deliver your
package you know i'm saying it ain't
gonna be like that betterhelp.com
diaz d-i-a-z that's betterhelp.com
diaz take control of your life and get
help that you deserve better help again
this doesn't mean they're going to put
you in a padded room do they put me in a
padded room no you rap to somebody you
talk to them and you feel better and
after about three or four weeks
guaranteed you at least get
a directional which way to go you'll
start going online they have activity
pages that you could work on cognitive
pages for you trust me
betterhelp.com diaz 10 off your first
month so in january you're ready to
[__] live like elvis presley you know
what i'm saying you're making moves like
elvis that's it and that's that that's
how i feel about it
but
me going to that gracie thing the night
was like therapy and i even told my co
my coach sean over there let me tell you
something i'm doing this for my health i
love working out i love lifting i love
eating right i try to eat right it's
tough around here
last night i had a couple cookies
saturday night at that party they had
those italian cookies with the seeds and
[__]
god damn i ate three of them that's all
there was i would ate more but they only
had three in that little tin can you
know they buy that ten [__] can
tremendous and they they only had three
like it was like a thin tin can like
termini's and philadelphia
terminis you ever go to terminus [__]
tremendous i order steve simone turned
me onto those [__] so i usually
order like christmas cookies from them
but the last couple of years the tins
been getting lighter and lighter like
last year was like this [__] skinny
to 10.
it was like two rows i'm like what the
[__] is going on my cookies
you know what i need a cookie like i
need a dick in my ass so
who needs a [__] i'm not ordering no
tens this year i'm not doing none of
that [__] that's what i was doing at
least for christmas shopping i buy a
couple tins
you know give them away this year i'm
gonna get some [__] uh restaurant
cards i'll give some of my friends cash
they got kids they rather [__] get
casual i'm gonna give him a tie how many
ties can you have even though a friend
of mine just called me the other days
like hey man can i borrow a tie i'm like
what are you [__] crazy how don't you
ever die he's like i don't know what
happened to all my ties i've lost him i
need something new to [__] win i go
we'll come over look at the ties what do
you think i'm johnny ties when was the
last time you saw me with a tie it's
like i'm going to [__] court
every other week i don't go to court no
more when i was going to court i was
dressing up [__] nice i might look
like a bum in [__] the regular days
but when i go up in front of a judge
you're looking like john gotti even my
[__] socks are [__] smoking socks
toenails have done the whole [__]
thing the fungi toenail now let's talk
about the ufc on saturday night let me
tell you my little [__] tate for the
story so
guys i'm not a professional gambler i
don't i don't even dig gambling that
much but if there's a sporting event on
i like to [__] tow
25 bucks just to watch the [__]
whatever
so this week the ufc was on [__]
great card the whole thing you know i'm
not into the ufc like i was before but i
still like certain fighters i love
dustin i love charles you know i like
certain guys i still love jon jones i
love [__] derrick lewis and his hot
balls i love all that [__] yeah
so you know saturday we had that [__]
christmas party i knew it i went over
there i told the guy listen do you mind
putting on the prelims i watch dominic
cruz the whole thing
so i told him because my daughter and
the kid go to
kickboxing together mma together so i
saw him at mma wednesday goes you coming
i go yeah i'm [__] coming but you
gotta do me a favor after the prelims on
for me goes don't worry i got army navy
the whole thing the guy had it all set
up
so
i went over that yesterday in the
afternoon friday night i was on
draftkings i went to look at what
special they run for the weekend because
that's why i like draftkings they run
specials and they had two
uh
what the [__] do they call them
they call them point boosts like uh
money boost like point boost
so they usually give you one every
couple days which means like if you bet
25 to win 32
which i would never make that [__]
bet anyway i'm not gonna sit there for
two hours to sweat out seven dollars i
might as well
pick up a [__] lemonade stand i'll
have more action
you know you look at 25 bucks 20 bucks
you want to win 45. you know what i'm
saying you want to you want to pick up
45 that means you you bet 25 you 120 you
had a good time nobody got rich you knew
this when you joined draftkings nobody
gets [__] rich you just have a good
time you make a little money you're all
right
so i see i saw they had two
uh
point boost option boost whatever
payment boost
for two fights so
saturday morning when i got up before i
had to do my errands and [__] i checked
out what george mazda bar has to say
george mazdaval always gives you a lock
go with george not the [__] uh
the championship fights he always gives
you a lock for the early fights always
he's good good as gold because he's got
my bookies so
i went on george he gave us the same you
know dustin amanda but he gave you a bam
bam tui tuavasa the guy that [__] you
ever see this guy he drinks [__] beer
out of his shoe at the end of a fight
and then when he walks off people pour
beer into his shoe last time he fought
somebody put hot sauce to this shoe
[__] tremendous though this time
i see he's fighting and i took the two
odds boost that's what they call odds
boost
so i said i got nothing to lose today
i'm gonna watch this far watch the
prelims and i'll watch i love [__]
pia tiavusa bam bam i put 25 on him with
the odds boost i think i won you collect
51 dollars again nobody's gonna get rich
but you have a good time it pays for
your [__] pretzels whatever the [__]
you're gonna eat pizza
and then i go what am i gonna bet in the
main card amanda nunez the [__] you
know
you better man the newness if you if you
bet 25 on amanda nunez i think you pick
up like three dollars i swear to god
it's like you lose money if you went
with amanda newness i'm like i'm not
betting that
i didn't know much about the jeff tate
fight and jeff whatever his name was i
didn't know much about what was going on
but i like dustin you know and i like
charles but i like dustin in this fight
that was like you know friday and then i
started thinking about it i saw the mma
graph that mma junkie put up i saw all
the grabs
nobody
was talking
about charles oliveira
that's when the old joey diaz joke comes
up you've never seen a bookie with a
part-time job
everybody
had dustin everybody
i was sitting there i'm like nobody's
going with aloe vera
and then somebody i think uh draftkings
of the ufc
did a twitter poll
and oliveira won that
but it wasn't for who's gonna win
tonight
is for who's the better welterweight
whatever the [__] he is 170 155 i'm not
sure
so i'm like okay that's a big difference
there
i go you know what it's 25 bucks
what if oliveira does go off tonight i
mean dustin deserves it he works hard
he's beat mcgregor great [__] run he
went on
did it exactly how i would do it if i
was going to do a run one man at a time
and but you know what
he never seen a boogie with a part-time
job i bet oliveira
and both of them [__] won but there
was a snag on the way to the [__]
thing
so i watched like
the first prelim the the chubby dude
that drinks out of the shoe
i why he [__] punched the [__] on
that dude that dude is still hearing
[__] birds i don't know where he is
dog he's still hearing [__] birds
that [__] so uh
we watched dominic cruz and you know the
fight came over i came home
i watched something with mercy and then
i put a fight on you know
and it was really weird that as i was
sitting down
john anak said
uh
you know
go to draftkings right now amanda nunez
is going off at this
but right now a hundred dollar bet on
draftkings wins you six hundred
if you put a hundred dollar down on
juliana pena you win 600. so again my
little junky mind went into work and i'm
like wait a second
you spend 20 bucks on worse things
like there's worse things you do with 20
bucks you you pick it gamble whatever
the [__] you know you ever been walking
around and you're like i'll get that
it's just 13 bucks 13 bucks or 13
[__] bucks but i'm sitting there and
i go what the [__] what's 25 on juliana
pena you know what and then i thought of
something else why don't i date spanish
women because i'm scared of them okay
i've always been scared of spanish women
let's get this [__] out in the open
right now
always since i'm a kid my mother was
spanish and i'm like you know what do i
really want to marry that not never
no
no no no love my mother miss her wish
all the best up there in heaven can't
wait to see it but you know what no no
no love spanish women have a lot of
[__] friends of the spanish woman
they take a bullet for you but if you
want peace of mind i can't date a
spanish woman when you're spanish you
can't date a spanish woman i leave that
to the jews and the italians you guys
love spanish women help yourself don't
come crying to me when you got an iron
buried in your [__] skull don't come
crying to me all right so i'm like
[__]
juliana pena i got to go with julianne
pena just for the small 25 you know what
i'm saying
joey d is luck first minute she gets
knocked down i'm like
what else is little this is the story of
my life i'm a bum dad and i'm a bum now
i'm watching this fight and all son
juliana she gets her in another thing
again then juliana gets out with a
[__] kamora then the round ends and
i'm like what the [__] is going on this
isn't bad
and all of a sudden second round juliana
went in there and laid
a [__]
ass weapon an ass weapon i gotta be
honest here brought tears to my eyes i
was so happy for that venezuelan chick
because like that's why and
dog when she choked her i go to myself i
go now you know why
i don't date spanish women you
understand me that my friends i love
them to death they're my [__] you
know i go to war i'm taking three little
chubby spanish women and i'll take my
chances [__] you [__] three
little mexican tanks a little cuban
shake that's got big tits and a little
gut that chick hasn't eaten in two days
she'll take your eye out i'm not [__]
around so
i i was so happy for julia i even put it
this fight was tremendous on twitter i
was [__] ecstatic so
that's how i felt last night i won like
i don't know one something 200 bucks on
a 25 [__] thing and guess what i'm
gonna lose it all on sunday and football
anyway so who gives a [__] nah i'm gonna
hold on to it the bowl season's coming
so now i'm gonna get my [__] uh money
ready because i'm not good with the
bowls i bet two i made two small bets
[__] per dan florentine on college
and i've lost both of them because he
liked him he's the kiss of death when it
comes to college even though i love him
to death
but anyway i want to talk to you about
one last thing and then we'll get the
[__] out of here because in a way these
pop cut these popco these
podcasts are about you know
what's going on the week what's going on
with my life some week i give you a
story that you've probably heard already
some week i talked to you about a
current event
and some week i tell you about how
something affected me and i got to be as
honest as i can with you
on this story you're not going to like
this [__] story but i'm going to tell
you it anyway
the jesse smellet thing was settled this
week in uh chicago
between you and i guys i had forgotten
all about it that you know life has been
moving straight ahead nobody's worried
about [__] jesse smilet and his
[__] so
i got to be as honest as i can with you
guys on this jesse smellette thing
because i don't think i told you this
jesse smellet was
one of the reasons but
the whole jesse splatter situation
got me thinking you ever get you ever
been in your life and you
you don't think i always talk about the
worst thing a man can do is think you
know
it puts you in weird prediction it puts
you in weird predicaments you have to
talk to you end up talking to better
help
that's why when you [__] think
because it opens up things for you
i remember when i first heard about the
jesse smellette thing i'm sure i
we cracked jokes on the church and then
the other night
when i found out that he had been
convicted i cracked a joke on twitter
from the greece's [__]
it's post time that's all great and
dandy but let me tell you something
a lot of things bothered me about l.a
a lot of [__] things bothered me
about l.a but if that's if i have to
narrow it down
to three things that convince me to
leave and you guys aren't gonna believe
this when i tell you i'm gonna tell you
anyway the number one thing that really
raised my eyebrow about something was
when i saw a documentary about the yoga
dude the [__] indian dude
that puts the the sweat yoga what's the
whatever the [__] it's called and he has
the little [__] thong and a bunch of
white chicks go in there on worship
boulevard and he sits there with a
microphone
all sweaty talking to these poor white
chicks and you know let's take the story
back to 20 years ago i'm in a barbecue
at a photographer's house the guy did my
head shot sweetheart of a guy
we're having a good time we're outside
and all of a sudden some chick is
talking to me and my wife
and she's telling us how she goes to
that yoga i forget the [__] name but
i'm sorry
bikram
bikram yoga and uh
you know and also at one point she goes
you don't understand
he touches me inside and i just remember
how i felt like look at this poor
[__] girl
this poor girl was raised in a great
house her father probably went to work
every [__] day
the [__] bust of the hump made
chocolate chip cookies for them two days
a week and [__] threw away the chips
ahoy worked really hard for this little
rotten [__] to come out to l.a and find
[__] solace and some [__] dirty
greasy [__] guy that smells like
hummus times 10. you know what i'm
saying like i i mean i can't deal with
this [__] at all and you know he smells
as bad as hummus and then you got to
[__] put the heat on there which
really you ever smell big thomas i never
had but i don't want to smell it either
i just know what lee's neck smells like
and i don't wanna i don't want no
[__] sweaty hummus and lee don't eat
hummus no more so
his neck don't sweat like that no more
took me [__] eight years to convince
him not to eat that hummus thank god now
[__]
boys had got into the hummus business
i'm gonna have to [__] tell them to
go [__] themselves i'm gonna have to
stick with [__] egg salad from now on
like i've been doing i love [__] egg
salad juice in jersey they know how to
make egg salad [__] bagel talk makes
an egg salad holy [__] bagel talk off
route 9 makes a [__]
red pepper cream cheese
you put it on something you think your
ads gonna [__] blow up that's how
good that is but anyway back to jesse
smaller in this [__] antics
i'm trying to be funny about it here but
i can't be funny about this
when jesse smellet did that i got to be
as honest as i can with you guys
it kind of bothered me the first thing
that bothered me was the bikram thing
that really bothered me i have a
daughter guys i have a daughter
you know i'm saying so i don't want
i'm raising it right there and bikram
fuckingville
with the rest of these weak [__]
people that would
you know i talked to you about going to
gracie yoga but i talked to you howard
i'm not looking to be johnny jiu jitsu
i'm not looking to uh go to the 10th
planet eddie you know has a goal because
that school
requires you to have a goal for your
training which i never had before i
would just go to jiu jitsu i never
really had a goal a purpose i was
training for for my 60th birthday i'd
like to go to a competition and compete
you know at uh
whatever but that's just a mind [__] you
follow you know i talk about mindfucks
that's just a mind [__] right there but
it's something that i'm looking at so i
have
roughly uh
15 i'm gonna be 60 and
i'm gonna be
58 59 in february so we got
february 19th
i got two months there so i got 14
months to train
to be ready for [__] uh a thing but
at least i'm doing that but i'm not
looking to be eddie bravo
i'm not looking to be in this contest
i'm not looking to be in the ufc i'm not
looking to do a celebrity death match i
would get killed anyway you know what
i'm saying like i'm not looking to do
any of that [__] it's just for health
and [__] uh therapeutic you know
talking to people it's it's getting out
there and talking to young guys it's
heart health it's so many [__] things
i look at it but a lot everybody
everybody that does something in la 50
is of their why they do it is what's it
gonna do for me
you guys know that movie uh fighter or
whatever the [__] about mma that
director was working out at street
sports when the word got out that that
director was at street sports their
[__] uh program grew by a hundred
[__] students why because they want
to get close to a director not because
they want to learn jiu jitsu so always
see the the with the square root of what
the [__] is going on here so
when all that [__] went down i tell you
why it bothered me as much as
it did that jesse smelleth thing
it bothered me that a guy
would fake
this
he put there was as many mis moving
pieces as when i kidnapped bella
for him there was no no he had more
moving pieces
that when i kidnap bella now any [__]
i didn't know this when i kidnap bella
the more moving pieces you have the
higher the chances of you getting caught
especially when you involve outside
people in fact he did the same thing i
did with vella he went against my
godmother her santeria wisdom never do
anything with three people two could
turn on you always do it with two or
four he just did all these things that
were very similar to what i did with ken
bella
but he did him i did him for cocaine
i did them to pick up thirty thousand
dollars i did it so i could get my dick
sucked
i did it so i could be cool i did it
from uh and half of these reasons i'm
lying to you the main reason why i
kidnapped bella was because i'm a
[__] junkie and i didn't want to pay
for a kilo i'd rather throw him in the
trunk of a car you know what i'm saying
but that's just me i don't want you to
[__] throw anybody in the trunk of a
car my point is
this guy went through all this [__]
all this [__]
so he could get a raise
on his show
and he wouldn't get fired or
you know it had something to do with
show
and then that makes me think of all the
desperation there is in l.a
then it made me think about would i do
that
would i do something like this
for a netflix special
went to be cool i was walking home from
the comedy store and two guys jumped me
and one [__] me in the ass
just so people could feel bad for me so
i get hired i mean
what have happened to hard work whatever
happened to [__] you know what i'm
saying so when this went down
it did bother me because i already had
issues with what was going on i had
issues with the [__] bikram yoga as
dumb as it sounds i know you people
going to go joey how did that affect you
it doesn't
doesn't affect me at all but it makes me
think if a woman puts that much trust
in something like that and i mean there
was tons of them there was tons of
people got
smoked by this guy then you got to think
of the harvey weinstein situation
how disgusting that was
the agents knew
the actors knew ben affleck knew brad
pitt knew they all knew but it was like
high school you know what i'm saying
there's some chicks that'll suck your
dick for a roll and we all know it
and harvey used his [__] influence
you sucking harvey's dick is like you
sucking my dick you're gonna have
[__] ptsd
somewhere along the line you know what
i'm saying so i wouldn't do that decide
it's just
that whole those two things you know and
then watch the exorcist i'll never
forget this i was just watching the
exorcist one night i think it was not i
ate the mushrooms with those guys but
myself when lee wouldn't eat the [__]
mushroom it tastes like [__] just eat
the [__] mushroom
and i went home and i was watching it
that's the night when i realized that
the devil does live in africa as dumb as
this sounds
but his summer house was la
like some while i was watching the
exorcist like i was on mushrooms and
[__] i was tripping but for some reason
that's where my mind went i was like you
know what
we all know the devil lives in [__]
africa
that's official with all the bad [__]
that happens in africa but
you know with all the mudslides and
harvey weinstein's and
bill cosby's and all this [__] was i
living in the right place it was the
jesse smellet case
that pushed me over the top that i was
like
these this is 50 of the people i have
around me that's that's a reality
60 of the people i have around me
would sell their grandmother
to hang out with anjali jolie just to go
to parties and say i'm dead serious it's
it's
it's [__] sad
but as dumb as this sounds that's the
kind of [__] i think about that's the
kind of [__] that bothers me that
my daughter
myself
and my wife are surrounded by people
that
by just people that would do something
like jesse smellette
to further their career
you know people that
would
you know trick women or women
suck his dick to get a movie role
while you're doing that movie role don't
you feel bad don't you i don't know
and then what i then i think about the
[__] you know you go to yoga to get
healthy and all of a sudden you get
tripped up by some guy
for his own sexual [__] whatever and
this goes on constantly there
but it's all those things that made me
honestly look at myself and go listen
i'm a [__] criminal i've kidnapped
[__] like i've done a lot of
bad [__] that i'm not [__] proud of
but i wouldn't do that like i wouldn't
do that [__]
and that's the jesse smellet thing
honest to god
and me coming home and a lot of other
things but it was the jesse smallett
thing that made me go
this is what i'm surrounded with
i got to get around some real people
there was the time hang stories all the
pedophile [__] i just said had it i just
had it i really did and i didn't have it
like
there's that i didn't it's not one of
those things
this was like in my mind that i was
thinking about these the people i'm
surrounded with out there
is this what i want from my family it's
like now
they've been telling you for i've been
sitting here
here and at the church telling you that
one day i went to burbank
and i just saw something that wasn't
right i had been to burbank a thousand
times guys
alberto crane's jiu jitsu school [__]
atomic records porto's my friend damon's
the house you know how many times
auditions i was in burbank [__] i
lived in [__] studio city i was
always in burbank i knew burbank left
and right i went to burbank at night
flappers
i would go to burbank and see how it was
dead after nine o'clock i would see how
you know one night i left a wallet at
flappers it fell out of my [__]
sweatpants in the middle of the street
it fell
i went all the way home parked and
realized i dropped my wallet i went all
the way to flappers and as i was making
the [__] right turn with flappers is
to park i saw my wallet that had been
sitting there for a half hour guys
nobody hit it it was 11 o'clock at night
maybe a little early i had a flight the
next day that's why i needed my id
nobody even touched that [__] wallet
let me tell you something when i got
home
i noticed my wallet was missing i got no
reason to lie to you guys i did 90 miles
an hour on magnolia boulevard
there was nobody on magnolia boulevard
not even a [__] cop
so i know burbank like the back of my
[__] hand when i went to porto's that
day or wherever i was going in the
pandemic
and i got out of my car
and i saw people jaywalking in burbank
i saw people jaywalking in burbank
which to you that doesn't mean to me it
doesn't mean anything i j walk all the
[__] time
but the people i was seeing jaywalking
burbank didn't live there
i'm not saying anything bad about their
race or that but they didn't live there
and they were just walking around and
the way the leaves were blowing around
i was getting like a cool wind that it
was going around me i just didn't feel
good and i said you know what
it's time to leave between jesse
this that this
the guy get hit in the head with the two
by four and i said it i said listen guys
and it's not going to be good and then
my buddy confirmed it
my fbi agent friend confirmed everything
i had said i didn't know that [__]
crime route groups
were going to go out there different
types of crews are going to go out there
to rob
you know not terry crews cruz c-r-e-w-s
i didn't know crews were gonna go out
there to rob
and guess what with all the [__] you
hear did you see what happened last week
the [__] president of the
police union
came out and said look if you're a
tourist don't come to l.a and i would
say the same thing for new york right
now i'm hearing what's going on in new
york it's a touristy time of the year i
know a lot of people cancel [__] because
on the 27th you got your kids got to be
[__] vaccine to go into the city so
that killed new york right there but if
you're a [__] tourist i don't want
you in new york city
this is the second year we can't go see
the tree
the lighting of the tree
it's just not [__] safe
so if i was a tourist i'd be honestly i
consider [__] uh tennessee i consider
[__] miami and i wouldn't even i'm
not
telling you to go there i'm just saying
consider [__] houston or something
like that and all these places aren't
[__] doing well either
so
for a cop to tell you that the guy the
president's union for the police that
then the chief of police came out here
he doesn't know what he's talking about
yes he does
yes he does you can't protect people on
hollywood boulevard and you can't
[__] protect people but with all this
[__] i still talk to people out there
that have kids
they're still out there we're kids now
again
i'm a felon i'm a [__] you know but
it wasn't about me when all that [__]
started going down out there i said it
to myself i go
i married a woman and i had to ask her
father for i am in marriage and i had to
have a lengthy conversation with my
mother-in-law
before i married my wife and i know a
lot of you guys that are married
and if you're not married hear what i'm
saying to you as soon as you say i do
you're responsible for that woman
whether you like her or not i don't care
what happens three years down the line
you're responsible for that woman and
that little girl i'm responsible for
so my responsibility in that situation
was to get them out of there
if i wanted to stay to advance my career
whatever the freedom i'm saying because
half those people are sitting there
waiting because they're advancing their
careers
i would advance my career but by myself
i'm not going to involve my daughter and
my child i mean you guys all saw a lady
got hit in the head with a [__] she
was walking with a kid with a stroller
that could be your wife mike as soon as
i heard stroller i was like that could
be any of our wives that have a kid
you know what they're doing out there is
not [__] bueno
and thank god but all these people will
continue to stay there
because of their careers despite
of what's going on for me that's [__]
bogus now they got a [__] lead now
they'll leave because there's mandates
out the yin-yang you know now though
[__] where they're gonna go now thank
god i left when i did so
what i wanted to get through to you guys
today was sometimes you don't know
what's gonna push you over the top
for me it was the just and i see
everybody's talking about the jesse
smallett thing
and they're not getting to the root of
the matter here the thing that affected
me the most
i mean yes he lied to the city of
chicago he had a bunch of people
thinking that whatever he got beat up
that's all great and dandy and it was a
[__] stupid move to do but
i'm looking at the type of person that
would do something like that
you know hey i'm the type of person that
tied up a guy and threw him in a trunk
of a car
again i did it for the square root to
snort coke
why would he do that he has everything
going he made it a phenomenal salary
he had everything good-looking kid
hollywood home
people in his life a great show and then
you got to see you got to look at what
else happened from him doing that
one of the number one shows at fox
there's five more episodes wraps up
their [__] suits and leave
that's gotta tell you that that was a
toxic [__] workplace not that i give
a [__] i don't this isn't about uh the
show or anything i'm not putting the
show down it was a great show i watched
it for like two seasons then it went
somewhere else crazy i didn't watch
anymore but the first two seasons
weren't bad at that show but if you
notice that also
it just went away nothing just goes away
when they're making that much money
food for thought [__] thank you
very much
for watching or listening to the podcast
today i love you [__] with all
my heart thank you for having my back
and uh that's it
we got maybe six more podcasts left and
it's 2020 [__] i love you guys
have a great week
today's the [__] mark that gets you
through
i'll see you wednesday tip top
[__] magoo now for a word from
our sponsors jack
all right i want to thank all you
savages
sorry about your finger there mikey
almost [__] bang this thing i'm
i want to thank you guys for watching
and supporting the podcast
we had a nice little time today talking
about that [__] mukiak
jessie smollett but anyway let's get the
party started with mid midro
listen to me
betterhelp.com
joey
diaz d-i-a-z the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy listen to me
nobody wants to go to therapy the word
therapy scares people it scares a guy
like me but guess what
it took me from point a to point z and
it could do the same for you many people
think therapy is for so-called crazy
people i'm crazy but you know therapy
doesn't mean something's wrong with you
it means you recognize
that we're all humans that we all have
emotions and we need to control them
that's it therapy is a tool to utilize
before things get worse i'm very happy
i reached out to betterhelp.com that
customized online therapy
is tremendous they gave me options with
video phone
or live chat
and you don't have to see somebody if
you don't want it you know what i'm
saying it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist
in less than 48 hours i feel great guys
i feel great this morning 8 45
9 15. half hour i have an option of 45
minutes it's whatever you need give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
just for the joint listeners get 10 off
your first month
if you use betterhelp.com
diaz that's better help b e t t e r
l
diaz take control your life and get the
help you deserve better help
the joint is also brought to you by
onyx.com listen it's that time of the
year again
everybody's joining gyms everybody's
doing this but are you taking care of
yourself are you getting your diet
together are you getting your
supplements together that's where anik
comes in go to honor.com right now
read look at the supplements they offer
from alpha brain the powder to the drink
to the pills that you could take if
alpha brain don't work for you there's a
hundred percent money-back guarantee all
right
and you keep the pills that's how strong
planet believes in their product
shroom tech immune shroom tech sport a
tremendous
new mood to mct all and it's got it all
but it starts with you go to on it you
see something you like pressing joey
joint
church whatever the [__]
joey's nut sack
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house on it is the best don't forget
about that i love you guys
and the joint is also brought to you by
me undies listen
me on these is the most comfortable pair
underwear you're ever wear in your life
and you want to spread this holiday
cheer they're comfortable they fit right
they feel great
and i'll tell you what they make a great
gift
with the new holiday prints me on these
is turning up the comfort this season
all me on these products are made with
soft breathable stretchy fabrics and me
undies justice and underwear anymore
they got loungewear they got sleepwear
they got matching pajama sets plush
robes or slippers but most importantly
they're all comfortable they got
something for grandma grandpa your aunts
your uncles even your [__] skinny
cousin there that
you don't know what he's up to these
days they're available in all sizes
extra small
through 4x me undies has a little
something for everybody on your list but
it's all up to you you want to go to
stores you can just go to meundies.com
right now that's it it's that easy they
got an offer to make your wig spin you
ready
first time buyers get 15 off and free
shipping right to your door that's it
that's the best deal you're gonna get on
the most comfortable underwear in the
world your days are fighting for your
life in the mall parking lot they come
to an end uncle joey canceled that that
said it's over 86 with a [__] wall to
get 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100
satisfaction go to meundies.com
joey that's
meundies.com a way better underwear than
those tighty whities you're wearing
meundies.com slash joey j-o-e-y i want
to thank better help i want to thank
honor i want to thank me undies but most
importantly i want to thank you savages
for supporting me and having my back on
a weekly [__] basis stay black have a
great day uncle joey loves you and i'll
see you guys wednesday tip top magoo
[Music]
stay black
you